urge pessoal bem vindos a mais um vídeo
e hoje vou ensinar como fazer dois
canais papel que se encaixa o maneira ou
outra e por fazerem elas vão precisar
dessas folhas a4 de impressora fita e o
gravador obra for é opcional mas fica
muito melhor que vocês usarem e rock vai
ficar muito mais resistente e que lhes
vai junto dela até o final e só uma
coisa vocês não tirem disco nice contra
ninguém eu fiquei pessoal sejam
responsáveis
i am the blues aos mesmos desafios perto
de um estado e vocês gostaram mesmo
deixa que eu já ganhou muito barulho que
ajuda bastante na divulgação da evolução
dos meus vídeos
inscreva se para acompanharem as coisas
que eu tenho que fazer é toda semana e
até a próxima